You've learned how to create branches and
how to keep track of which branches contain which commits, using diagrams.
Now, let's take a look at how to combine changes from multiple branches into
a single version.
Since the coins branch is finished,
I'd like to incorporate the changes into the master branch.
If no changes had been made to the master in the meantime, back when I
first started it, I could just update the label to be where I am now.
But changes have been made in master.
So I'll need to somehow combine the coin branch, with the master branch and
create a single version that contains all the changes from both.
Git can actually combine the master branch with the coin branch automatically,
which is pretty impressive.
To get an idea of how this works, let's look at a simple example first.
Suppose two people, I'll call them Jake and
Rachel, are editing two copies of the same file independently.
You can imagine that this is the game.js file from the Asteroids repository or
any other file, really.
At the beginning of the day, they both start with the same version of the file.
During the day, each of them makes some changes, possibly adding some lines, or
removing some lines.
At the end of the day,
Jake's version of the file contains some lines of content.
We'll refer to them as B, D and E.
Now of course, in reality,
these would be lines of code or may be instructions for a recipe.
But I'm using letters instead, so
that you can focus on how to create a combined version of file without getting
bugged down by thinking about the specific content.
Similarly Rachel's version contained a couple of lines.
A, B, C and D.
Now, Jake and Rachel want to combine their two files into a single version with
both of their changes.
For each line, mark whether you think it should be present in the final file.
Pick yes if it should definitely be in the file.
No if definitely not.
And unknown if it's impossible to figure this out from the information you have.
This is a hard question, so don't worry about getting it right on the first try.
Just try your best and think about each line individually